[Music]
welcome to the ultimate
iphone 12 camera test we have the 12 pro
max the 12
pro the 12 mini and the 12. now the
biggest differences between the pro
and just the regular 12 is the fact that
these do have three lenses they have
lidar and these only have two lenses
these do not have telephoto the
difference between
the 12 pro max the 12 pro is that the 12
pro
max has a 2.5 telephoto lens it also has
a larger sensor in the wide angle lens
and it has sensor shift technology which
allows
for better stabilization this is gonna
be kind of an interesting test because
the cameras on all of these are very
similar so i kind of just wanted to show
you guys that no matter which phone you
decide to choose you're gonna get an
incredible image you're also getting
dolby vision hdr
on all of these devices the only real
difference is you can shoot 60 frames a
second in dolby vision hdr on the pros
and you can only shoot 30 on the regular
12s so
let's get testing where shall i start
i see tyler it's okay it actually it
looks cool because it's like i'm framing
it right now just to get the vase
and then when i zoom out tyler in the
corner
now on the 12 pro max this is where the
real differences
are going to be happening because this
has the 2.5x zoom and the pro
only has the two i'm gonna take a couple
of pictures to show you
the differences in the zoom
it's actually a huge difference i'm
pretty shocked where's the dog
hey dog hi buddy hey maddie
can you please give me attention
[Music]
so i think you guys get the point these
don't have a telephoto
maddie do you want joe biden do you need
joe biden
so now i'm gonna test out portrait mode
on all four of these and the biggest
difference
with the 12 pro max is that it does have
that telephoto lens so that's going to
give you
a little bit different of a portrait
mode shot so jenna
take it away and do i look okay do i
look funny
subpar
[Music]
jenna great work
foreign
[Music]
to start out our video test we're going
to do a comparison between the 12 pro
max and the 12 pro because the
differences between this
is the 12 pro max has the 2.5 x zoom it
has the
larger sensor for the wide angle and it
has the new sensor shift technology to
get some better stabilization
so let's see what these look like this
is the test that i've been
very interested in trying
[Music]
[Applause]
i just saw a lizard i saw a lizard i
can't even make this up
2.5 maybe we can see him are you here
show yourself to me
[Music]
i think he's gone okay let's check this
out
oh boy all righty so look at them side
by side i did notice a slight difference
on the pro max because it looked a
little more
flowy kind of i guess angelic like
i mean that could just be my hair
flowing in the wind or
it could be the sensor shift technology
which
is probably most likely i'll probably
have a better idea when i look at
the computer but what do you guys think
[Music]
[Applause]
okay so now i'm going to pop on the mini
this is the test that i want to see
the 12 mini versus the 12 pro max like
look how small this is in comparison
do you see that jenna yeah i'm wow
same brain so you're able to do dolby
vision hdr 60 frames a second on the pro
max and on the regular 12
you can only do 30 frames so i will give
you a demonstration of what that looks
like when you do slow down the footage
if you're shooting in 60 frames and you
slow that down by 50 you'll definitely
notice that it's much
more smooth so let's do a quick little
test here
see what we got
[Music]
this is just a very simple test shooting
both cameras 30 frames a second and
showing you the differences between the
zoom
or i guess lack thereof zoom on the mini
oh no it's still ultra wide you can see
my other phone in it hold on there we go
so there's our ultra wide of the pool
there's our wide angle see if you guys
could notice any stabilization
differences between the two
because like we've mentioned many times
the censorship technology is only on the
wide angle
on the pro max not the 12
or the 12 pro look at that zoom i can
see that pumpkin light so i want to give
you guys a little demo of the
front-facing camera
it's the same on the other two so i'm
just gonna show you between
the mini and the max here we go so this
is the pro max that i'm looking at right
now
and here's the mini that i'm looking at
uh i'm trying to make sure i'm looking
at the lens on at least one of them
because you can tell if you're not like
if like right now i'm looking at myself
on the pro max
always guys look at the lens when you're
[Music]
vlogging
okay let's take some selfies the one
thing that is cool is when you do rotate
this
horizontal this will give you the wide
angle lens so it'll switch from the
zoomed in
front-facing selfie to a little bit
wider of a view so here's the wide angle
and here's the zoomed in this helps you
fit more people into the frame if you're
doing some group shots
i like it looks good so for my personal
devices i ordered the promax and silver
and then i impulse purchased the white
mini i woke up at 5 a.m bought this one
and then just as i was about to go back
to sleep i was like uh no i want what
i should i should i should i do i should
do it and i did it i did it i did it
you're not do it don't you won't do it
you did it
as you can tell it's still light out
which means we're not gonna be able to
test night mode so let's wait for the
sun to go down
and i'm gonna show you guys the night
mode photos plus a night mode time lapse
so tonight
we test first
wait for the sun to go down
[Music]
i'm exhausted took a few shots before we
got back here
after we ate dinner and i'm so
incredibly impressed by the pro max like
it's just
it's so like take a look at these this
is what it looks like with no night mode
and now here's night mode on
i know pretty impressive so we've got
some cool lights maybe we can try some
light painting
let's see what we can get and then i
gotta go to bed i haven't slept in four
weeks
so
[Music]
mophies are plugged in we've got the new
tumi one
that they have so these are gonna keep
these powered
all night long i've got the brightness
turned down
and we are gonna set these time lapses
here we go
i'm so nervous
[Music]
[Applause]
it is so windy out there
it was windy all night and i'm just
gonna say
the time lapses did not turn out how i
had hoped
my sister woke up around 5 30 and said
that the pro max had shut off because
it was so windy that the mophie cable
actually got pulled out of
the pro max so the time lapses that
we've ended up with
not the best because it was so windy so
everything is kind of
very unstable and sort of shaky but all
in all i'm pretty impressed with how
well
this did perform i even took some photos
inside
of maddie and just sort of around the
house and it's really impressive to
see some of the photos and how you're
able to get such detail
in not only the shadows but also pull
out a lot of the highlights
so cool so that's it for this video i
hope you guys enjoyed it i'm now gonna
pack up
and head back to make more fun videos on
the iphone 12 for you guys i had so much
fun testing these out and i'm so
impressed with the performance
across all four of these models i think
honestly the conclusion that i've come
to is
depending upon what you're looking for
in a phone all four of these models are
incredibly impressive obviously if you
want the higher end model with a bigger
screen and a little bit better
performance in cameras
then obviously you're gonna go for the
max but for anybody that does end up
getting the 12 or the 12 mini
you're not going to be disappointed so
i'm going to pack up now
look at all this gear that we've brought
when i could just film everything
on a phone
jenna said that i didn't look good no no
but it's looked like this for the whole
video
[Music]
[Applause]
you